vous êtes contente je suis ravie c'est
la première voiture toute neuve toute
neuve
[Musique]
c'est vraiment le jouet quoi mon cadeau
de Noël
[Musique]
si vous voulez vous allez dans un
magasin vous choisissez une robe
longuement en pensant quand vous les
allez la mettre et pourquoi vous allez
la mettre ou une de vos amis ou une de
vos soeurs vous donne une robe elle est
neuve pour vous mais enfin elle a déjà
été portée et c'est pas la c'est pas la
même chose quelque chose de complètement
neuf qui
s'appropriété à soi en premier
[Musique]
je suis peut-être comme un enfant mais
c'est comme ça que je réagis
[Applaudissements]